hello to all and thank you for
joining us in physical presence in
the press room of the
european commission thank you also for
following us live online by satellite
it is Thursday 11 November
and I would like to congratulate our friends our
Polish colleagues  for their national holiday
the enemy
[Music]
international transit
svx rigid panels
my dreams are being
made man
with you
repeat
organized
this weekend on the roads in
2010 joint
spock meeting at the ministry we forget everything we
won
truck skills  so
commissionaire situation h but nesta on fuel oil
for this for all elite seniors
one in blood and humanitarian
weekend has no basis as a form
of atg following
x propose migrants smiling
cndd to buddha and then i have today
an update on the
president's agenda fender hatred the president
is still traveling in washington
dc this afternoon she will address via
videoconference  ence at the betting forum
on peace and later today she will
meet with the heads of
diplomatic missions of member states in
the united states
vein regarding all
mujahid meetings ministry has put in
[Music]
review
keep
on said
johnny present title your
[Music  ]
final
destination
mike green bay the road
to provide ue
[Music]
what jo
de
turin naples
italy
515 mm
migration policy
common
shares and
[Music]
shares
all
and all
its inhabitants of tuning points
despite six
as specific binding
exchange flattering
but
yes
visa project in sometimes folk like
projectiles
emergency assistance everything
[Music]
the next program for a
long time and
allocation fund management also aims to
save six points must ministers
express themselves in the
[Music]
urban environment
specific to the question of shows
prospects
because if this crime  is sent each
autumn by
the same channel
this
[Music]
complex situation
of
st
la pot
ex  plore
6 ah yes
it's
been a long time
[Music]
that there is this access
vivendi
situation of
our store and brabham instrumental
was
right
away
he said this same stage at
i thought madness the
mission
of
google
the pick-  ups rue pitt who
is from france
yes a contact clause and i'm with you
for it is out of mind tricks in crisis
without
help
an email to foot english
we
need you
tonight
managing exception situation
[Music]
thus
only
campsites log in to swing the false
promises off
the cachet correcting the bugs remains
optional as such
the liner of the
people and this ransacking of an axis wake and we
have band reign
good I you hear me yes otherwise I
hear you  very badly because I
hope it will be ok
questions about the trip of mr
michel who met the
polish prime minister yesterday
it seems that they answered that according to
him and according to a legal opinion from the legal service
of the council
the commission could not  participate in the
creation of protective walls
and barbed wire
at the Polish borders, in particular
is this legal opinion shared
by the commission is the
commission preparing concrete initiatives
the formula is Mr
michel who was asked by the
European council is a sub-
question about the situation of these migrants
is that for the moment
officials of the commission
members of the commission have access to the
area concerned which is prohibited by
poland to ngos humanitarian workers and
journalists  thank you very much
any sincerity of the questions on the
first explained in detail
the extent of our funding and
the other support for the management of the
external borders
which is very concrete in terms
of equipment and a lot of many
concrete things that we finance  he
will now answer and under the
more specific question if the
barbed wire can be financed
I will allow myself to give  maybe a
reminder of the whole whole context of this
of this debate
it is a long standing position of the
european commission that barbed wire
or walls are not funded by the
european budget
it is the responsibility of the
member states to
to carry out border controls
and it is also the role of determining
how this is going to be done and as we
have repeatedly pointed out
European law as such does
not exclude the use
of barriers for the purposes of
border control this is not
something that is disputed and in
fact
in several member states this
has been done with national funding
the commission has always
encouraged member states to use
border control measures
that are either  both effective and
proportionate on the basis of a
risk analysis on the basis of operational cooperation
at European level on the
basis of information exchange is
fully  clearly in line with fundamental rights
in and in this context European funds
are used as slabs
explained on a very large scale to
strengthen Member States
' border control capacities of
a wide of a wide of a wide range of
way with fi co financing of
the infrastructure
of surveillance control systems equipment this
operational support and that is all
that is needed at the external borders
and therefore as frozen as I also
pointed out in the
current multiannual financial framework 6 4  billions
of euros will be specifically allocated
to the member states for this purpose we
will also quickly publish
a document more reserved for a sheet
which explains to you in perhaps a little more
detail who are the
funding people that we that we
provide to the member states and how much
this represents for each mans state
thank you very much so this is not a
position I tell you that  if you like, but
it's our long-standing position which
agreed with the
European parliaments that the financing of the
European budget will not
support the barbed wire on the second
question
and on your second question concerning
the access of colleagues from the committee  at
the Polish border
I have nothing new to announce the
our dialogue with the
Polish authorities continues on this subject we
still do not have confirmation
that colleagues from the committee would be
authorized
to go to the border obviously we
continue to  underline the importance for
our two of such a list
thank you very much and what else is
question for adalbert on this subject
I think georges to a question to
pardon first jean pierre to a
question of the follow-
ups will  y jean-pierre these people because not said
light
adalbert answered my question at the last minute
so everything is up for me
too
so these cases I will give the floor to
[Music]
2 to be clear low  s events financing
review awards wire the world his side
ben arous the swedes of abba forms
at what it was just to write about michel are
worried about the risks of telling you
league report briouze returns there to france
to disperse a hobby
foreign ministers  camtel
clearly des world wish to be discussed
you for kids run by any think in
commissions or position which has been
grid os est oui dit le
match entre l'aso adalbert expressed
Clélia believe in the French position
no
league 1 on Sunday during this  final
long standing position s is quickly
the
meetings woods 35 years or october in
fall from his choices british gas gas
gas and
italgas
[Music]
to offshore drilling
there
[Music]
there will
be everything marenzio
georges
d'  albert
[Music]
like everything is possible where
albert
barnabé la
turbie is built there I wanted to ask you for
a comment on what Mr.
Caching said this morning
in particular  lier will hunting europe
very swing styles at the wheel club de
bordeaux n y fit château fenart orgas
d'heure had common right to be
fonts lithuanian leadership sanaa de
[Music]
picking so we in essence the threat
to cut off the gas which  arrive via
belarus
thank you david for your for your question
listen gas is a is a resource a
resource of primary necessity and
should not be used as a
geopolitical weapon like
human beings
should not be used as a weapon either
geopolitical weapon it is necessary that the hurdles
the facts must be made clear
and the situation must be clarified
there is a very clear reason
why the European Union has put in
place four series of sanctions against
the Lukashenko regime
over the course of  of the year namely the
belarusian presidential elections
fassi proud doubt 20
in 2020 and the subsequent crackdown
against the belarusian people by the
authorities today  the
ongoing discussions are discussions that are
also based on the new threats
coming from the lukashenko regime he
is the one who made sure to defy
all existing norms
he is the one who made sure
to use human beings  to
exploit them to put them in the
teeth of the teeth of in inhuman situations
today and these are the
reasons why the European Union is
taking action and
ensuring that it will never be able to accept
this kind of situation
and  allow me to
remind david what
the hate based president said yesterday after her
meeting with the presidents lease of the
white house where they discussed the
issue of the situation at the border
between belarus is the
external borders of the european union  from
poland lithuania and latvia the
president made it clear that the
situation that has been created is not
a bill haas situation and is not a
bilateral issue between the  poland and
lithuania latvia and belarus but
it's a question for the
entire european union
it's a it's a
year it's on the part of the belarusian
authoritarian regime to destabilize
its neighbors democratic
this
this methods who who who  we are
who we know that we have
also seen in previous elections
there have been deaths influenced by
elections we have seen cyber attacks
attacks target computer condé
excuse me I translated life
from English and we  have we
also seen the volume of disinformation
circulating so now we have this
hybrid attack which
instrumentalizes migrants and there is therefore a
temptation to add other instruments
depression but
I remind you at the conclusion of the
president
during this point  press release after the
meeting with prisons in the united states
she clearly said that we will
protect our democracies from these
cynical geopolitical power games
q  who are at work at our
border
are there any other questions on this
subject
from regulars a follow-up question
yes thank you
because I understand very well the
position you are expressing but there in
addition to the  use of migrants as
hama political game etc there is a problem
let's say even bigger in the sense
that the gas to heat the houses of
europe 1 and so there you go and so
do you fear in some way
a worsening of the situation
compared to the  gas prices and all that
second element if I can in for
you because yesterday you explained to us
that the president has in an interview with
an American channel she said that
mr putin should exercise his
influence by hiding it yesterday
the kremlin has  let know the answer that
mr putin gave to the same
request of chancellor merkel
saying the european union must speak
directly with belarus so
are you going to speak directly
with the thank you
there are a lot of opinions on the first
question on the gas obviously so it
will be a new tool in the attack
bridle if it ever adds to the
situation the attack that is deployed by
the belarus regimes we have seen of
threat what we  let's be clear
and we're not going to be
intimidated that's the only thing i
can tell you about the things
we saw yesterday today regarding the
stance and possible action
by the government of the abdel
russian regime in  against
the supply of gas to the countries of
the european union on the second
question david i can only
repeat i can only repeat is that
the president said it will be
mans eloquent manners obviously we
think  that the Russian president has had little
influence on the beautiful Russian regimes and that
she him we invite him
we invite him to
try to convince the
Belarusian regimes to stop this
hybrid attack which is not in the
personal interest  nne we also mentioned
through the clowns the previous days
what is the extent of the contacts
we have with the regimes at
different levels and I can avoid
nabila reminded where there is indeed
david peter I think l  said himself
on this podium that is moreover the high
representative said it yesterday in parliament
that yes we are going
to canvass we also canvassed the authorities of minsk
through our diplomatic mission
through the diplomatic mission between
brussels
but he  repeated once again that and
our delegation a means is also in the
process of louise reaching out to
the Belarusian authorities
that said, we are doing what
we can to discuss with them
knowing all the same that they know very
well what  they are doing
they know very well that they are
using migrants in a year
as an instrument and they are
doing useful
disinformation disinfo campaigns  rmation and they
are putting pressure
on
the borders our room
obviously the instrument that we that
we are going to use that we are
already using and that we are going to extend
the use of are the sanctions it is
clear to us  that it is the answer who
who who who should speak in very
strong and very clear terms to the water
regime Belarusian regime the president has
mentioned many times
lately in her statements
the fact that we are going to push is
proposed for the extent  existing sanctions
and the president also mentioned
that we are going to
explore the legal avenues by
which we are going to be able to
introduce sanctions, including
blacklisting, against the
airlines of the airlines
which bring migrants to Belarus
to be pushed into  border with
Poland and therefore who participate in the game
of migrant smuggling orchestrated by
the Belarusian regimes is  con you
could see maybe during the
press briefing given last night it was also a
subject that was raised at the
white house is clearly the conclusion is
that we are going to align and coordinate
our practical actions with the
united states on the subject  of the means
that are used to bring
migrants here so it concerns
cooperation with the countries of origin but
also the action against the
airlines in question
is there any other questions on this
subject so the  external aspects of the
situation we have at the
border
if you still have questions
otherwise nabila is still here
it is not the case so thank you nabila and
I will now broaden the fields
to other questions that could
interest you today
[Music]
they say